herzlich willkommen zu zdf heute live es
ist tag 8 des russischen angriffskriegs
auf die ukraine und an diesem tag
sprechen sie fast gleichzeitig der
russische präsident putin und der
ukrainische präsident selensky
diese menschen kämpfen für russland für
die entnazifizierung der ukraine das
kein anti russland das seit jahren vom
westen direkt vor unserer grenze
aufgebaut wird existieren kann unser
volk ist stolz auf unsere streitkräfte
gott behüte wenn es uns nicht mehr gibt
werden lettland litauen und island als
nächstes dran sein dann moldawien
georgien und polen und so werden sie
weiter marschieren bis zur berliner
mauer glauben sie mir die welt muss ihre
stärke demonstrieren ohne zu kämpfen
ohne mit leben zu bezahlen weil die
stärke in der diplomatie liegt
so die aufrufe die worte von selen ski
und zu putin muss man sagen dass er
gesagt hat in seiner ansprache russlands
militärische spezialoperation laufe nach
plan weiterhin kein wort von einem
angriffskrieg reden wir mit christian
sehr darüber unseren korrespondenten in
moskau christian du hast die rede auch
verfolgt von putin was sollte das was
will er damit bezwecken es ist ja mehr
oder weniger inhaltlich so ähnlich
gewesen die seine erklärung am
donnerstagmorgen quasi die
kriegserklärung
ja das war eine fernsehansprache die
auch hier im staatsfernsehen
ausgestrahlt wurde und das war eine rede
die vor allem nach innen gerichtet war
nicht so sehr nach außen die
kriegserklärung die war ja sehr nach
außen gerichtet auch mit beschimpfungen
nochmal richtung westen richtung ukraine
richtung nato hier ging es vor allem
noch mal um diesen konflikt und warum
dieser einsatz den russland da gerade
macht warum der so wichtig ist das hat
er versucht den russinnen und russen
noch mal zu erklären ich kann vielleicht
noch mal ein paar zitate bringen
er sagte während der operation in der
ukraine handeln russische soldaten und
offiziere mutig wie echte helden oder
der verlauf der feindseligkeiten in der
ukraine zeigt dass russland gegen
neonazis kämpft also dieses narrativ
wird auch immer wieder wiederholt und
dann was auffällig war heute dass er
sehr lange sich dem thema russische
opfer gewidmet hat das wurde in der
vergangenheit immer vermieden gestern
gab es erstmals zahlen
498 russische opfer die ukraine die geht
von viel höheren zahlen aus spricht von
9000 opfern die genaue zahl die kennen
wir natürlich nicht aber es ist doch
auffällig dass putin jetzt so offen
darüber spricht und er spricht davon
entschädigungszahlen für die familien
für jedes opfer sollen die familien rund
sieben millionen rubel bekommen das
wären umgerechnet rund 62.000 euro und
ich glaube er will damit sagen erst mal
dass die kriegskasse gut gefüllt ist
dass man sich das leisten kann und wenn
man das natürlich hochrechnet auf die
opferzahlen will er damit glaube ich
implizit auch sagen dass die opferzahlen
nicht so hoch sind wie von der ukraine
behauptet so weit zu der rede von putin
nun hat es ja heute tatsächlich
verhandlungen gegeben eine erste runde
hat es schon gegeben heute eine zweite
runde im westen von belarus mit
vertretern der ukraine mit vertretern
von russland was ist da rausgekommen was
ist da zu hören christian
die gespräche zunächst einmal hat hier
das staatsfernsehen auch wieder bilder
gezeigt die liefen hier in heavy
rotation könnte man so sagen immer die
wieder dieses begrüßungsritual wo sich
die verhandlungsführer gegenseitig
begrüßt haben mit shake hands oder auch
mit der faust hier will man glaube ich
zeigen dass russland auf einem guten weg
ist mit den gesprächen russland hat er
immer gesagt man sei gesprächsbereit
aber wirklich zählbares aus den
gesprächen
ist erstmal zunächst nicht
herausgekommen wie es hieß jetzt eben
kam noch die anmeldung dass die ukraine
und russland sich zumindest auf
menschliche korridore verständigt haben
aber soll eine weitere gesprächsrunde
geben und es könnte dann weitere
gespräche anfang nächster woche geben
christian selben vielen vielen dank für
diese einschätzungen und das einordnen
aus moskau es ist tag 8 eines russischen
angriffskriegs auf die ukraine wir sehen
den ganzen tag auch heute wieder bilder
von granaten von raketen die auch zivile
gebäude zerstören kilometerlang der
konvoi russischer panzer die
aufzurollen fliehende menschen und auch
zivilisten die mit bloßen händen
versuchen panzer aufzuhalten man fragt
sich russland ist militärisch haushoch
überlegen die ukrainische luftwaffe
scheint ausgeschaltet zu sein ist es nur
noch eine frage von tagen dass russland
gegenüber der ukraine siegen wird gibt
es überhaupt noch ein fenster für
verhandlungen ernsthafte verhandlungen
die zu einem erfolg führen darüber
wollen wir reden mit der
verteidigungsexpertin claudia major von
der stiftung wissenschaft und politik
ich begrüße sie ganz herzlich schön dass
sie mit dabei sind und wir haben den
schweizer diplomaten und
politikwissenschaftler tim guldimann der
von 2014 bis 15 sondergesandter der osze
für die ukraine war vielen dank dass
auch sie aus berlin zugeschaltet mit
dabei sind für guten abend
gut' ist russland überhaupt an
ernsthaften verhandlungen interessiert
ist das alles friedens propaganda sie
haben auch ein bisschen die rede
verfolgt von putin frau major haben sie
da noch hoffnungen dass es auf
diplomatischem weg zu frieden zu einem
schweigen der waffen kommt
vielversprechend war die rede von putin
ja eigentlich nicht
möglicherweise kann es zu einem
vorübergehenden schweigen der waffen
kommen aber es wird kein das wird zu
keinem zweck einer friedlichen lösung
kommen weil russland ganz klar gemacht
hat dass es von den übergeordneten ziel
die ukraine zu kontrollieren nicht
abrücken wird und darum müssen wir uns
auseinandersetzen es wird von diesem
ziel nicht abrücken das heißt es wird in
den tagen noch brutaler werden das
einzige was momentan möglich wäre wäre
wirklich eine frau nach hause
und von der höheren wir bisher nichts es
hat jetzt eine eilmeldung gegeben die
ukraine und russland haben sich auf
sicherheitskorridor geeinigt was ist
davon zu halten ist das eine kleine
chance zivilisten vielleicht doch aus zu
kriegen
es ist eine begrüßenswerte chance wenn
die wirklich eingehalten werden aber wir
müssen da durch unterscheiden zwischen
der zwischen dem akuten krisen
management wo solche entscheidungen wie
die korridore sehr gut sind und der
übergeordneten politischen frage und
dort haben sich die position nicht
verändert die ukraine möchte ein
souveräner staat bleiben möchte
eigenständig bleiben und russland möchte
die ukraine de facto an einen vasallen
staat verwandeln der abhängigkeit von ge
abhängig von russland ist und russland
de facto untergeordnet ist das sind zwei
völlig gegensätzliche positionen das
heißt wir können jetzt hoffen in der
akuten situation eine linderung für die
bevölkerung zu finden über die korridore
über eine feuerpause aber wir sind weit
entfernt davon der den politischen
knackpunkt der politischen frage
dahinter wie eigenständig darf die
ukraine seien davon sind wir meilenweit
entfernt und da sehe ich keine lösung in
absehbarer zeit
bevor jetzt gemeinsam auch mit ihnen
herrn guldimann uns die militärische
lage und die bedeutung die situation
eben für potenzielle verhandlungen eben
anschauen einen blick auf das was heute
geschehen ist hat schon gesagt auch
heute wieder granaten raketen und viel
gefahr für die menschen in der ukraine
eine zusammenfassung des heutigen tages
mario pohl und reaktion zwei städte im
süden am meer was dort gerade passiert
dazu erreichen uns fast keine bilder nur
verzweifelte schwer überprüfbare
hilferufe per twitter diese aus mario
pohl das hier ist das einkaufscenter in
meiner nähe wir haben keinen strom kein
wasser sind abgeschnitten humanitäre
katastrophe völkermord ich habe keine
worte
ein video schnipsel im internet zeigt
den ausgebrannten supermarkt noch ein
zweiter sei zerstört worden heißt es
offenbar wurden gezielt die essens
reserven bombardiert
440.000 einwohner unter dauerbeschuss 14
stunden am stück und ein fassungsloser
bürgermeister
liebe mitbürger von mario pohl heute war
der härteste und brutalste tag dieses
krieges bis jetzt sie wollen uns einfach
nur alle zerstören
anders als in mariupol scheint der
militärische widerstand in trabzon
gebrochen fast 300.000 einwohner und die
ukrainische armee abgezogen stattdessen
sollen russische panzer in den strassen
ein einwohner berichtet
die panzer stehen vor meinem fenster
vielleicht zehn meter entfernt soldaten
feuerten warnschüsse ab und sagen uns
zivilisten dass wir nicht mehr vor die
tür dürfen
und dann noch diese aufnahmen aus dem
süden die nichts gutes ahnen lassen
russische kriegs und landungsschiffe
liegen vor dessau eine millionenstadt
wappnet sich für den wohl bevorstehenden
großangriff genau wie skf tut
doch der russische militärkonvoi im
norden der hauptstadt von dem so viel
die rede war kommt nicht voran
ukrainische gegenwehr staus und pannen
hätten ihn 30 kilometer vor dem
stadtrand vorerst ausgebremst glaubt der
britische geheimdienst twitter bilder
wie dieses könnte ein beleg dafür sein
manche kleinstadt umkehr warum ist aber
schon bis ins mark getroffen
borodjanka 60 kilometer vor kiew im
zentrum ein einziges trümmerfeld tote
und verletzte unklar beschwörend redet
der ukrainische präsident auf die
russischen soldaten ein
geht nach hause nehmt eure armee mit
sagt eurem kommandeur dass er nicht
stern wollte sondern leben
doch die zerstörung der ukraine geht
weiter
im nordosten von kiew seit beginn der
kämpfe fallen hier bombe mitten in die
wohngebiete sieben tage krieg heißt für
die betreuung der hochschwangeren der
stadt sieben tage geburten hilfe im
bunker 46 babys kamen so schon zur welt
fragen wir den schweizer diplomaten
politikwissenschaftler herr guldimann
wenn sie diese bilder sehen glauben sie
dann sie kennen die ukraine sie kennen
den kreml sie kennen putin glauben sie
dann noch an eine chance für ernsthafte
verhandlungen die irgendwie zu einer
waffenruhe zu frieden führen ich glaube
eine waffenruhe kann wäre nur möglich
wenn sie im interesse von russland wäre
sie widerspricht an sich den
ankündigungen nämlich das ziel die
ukraine zu beherrschen und das ist dass
krieg sie so wie es erklärt worden ist
wenn das natürlich stockt dann könnte
sich die frage stellen ist es im
interesse von russland von putin quasi
eine feuerpause zu haben um dann zu
schauen von einer vermeintlichen
position der stärke aus wie man weitere
ziele erreichen kann das interessante an
den jetzigen gesprächen dieser nicht
dass man etwas erwarten kann von ihnen
sondern das auf der anderen seite sind
die vertreter der ukrainischen
demokratisch gewählten regierung die
jetzt noch quasi die andere seite
darstellt das ziel der operation ist ja
nachgerade diese regierung
auszuwechseln nicht und wie das
passieren soll ist der militärische weg
ob das erfolgreich ist wird sich zeigen
ich glaube es hängt vor allem davon ab
was passiert in den nächsten tagen wie
erfolgreich ist dieser vorstoß aus kiew
es könnte sein dass solche korridore
über die die erwähnt worden sind die
situation in dem sinne erleichtern das
dann mit einer ganz massiven
bombardierung der stadt quasi ohne den
vor ort zu haben es wird die
zivilbevölkerung massiv bombardiert das
ziel zu versuchen zu erreichen ich habe
aber meine zweifel
klitschko der bürgermeister von kiew hat
vor 2 stunden gegenüber reuters der
agentur noch einmal gesagt wie wilmots
surrender wir werden also nicht
kapitulieren wenn russland aber jetzt ja
nun so überlegen ist frau maria und die
ukraine trotz dieser unterlegenheit
nicht kapitulieren wollen dann gibt es
ja eigentlich überhaupt gar keine chance
auf verhandlungen oder
also von ukrainischer seite ist klar
gemacht worden dass sie nicht
kapitulieren und nicht aufgeben wollen
sondern dass sie eher beispielsweise
sich in den westen des landes
zurückziehen wollen aber ich glaube was
ja wohl die man eben sagt das noch mal
ganz wichtig zu unterstreichen wenn man
sich die ziele russlands ansieht die
auch in den letzten tagen sehr klar
geworden sind muss man sich der
bereitschaft zur brutalität von der
russischen seite gegenüber sehr klar
sein die ziele sind relativ klar
kommuniziert worden das ist die einnahme
von kiew das sehen wir jetzt gerade ist
der systemwechsel
das heißt kein demokratisch gewählte
regierung mehr sondern eigentlich ein
militärregime das ist die ablösung der
eliten das läuft unter dem schrecklichen
russischen euphemismus von
entnazifizierung also ein kompletter
austausch der innigen und es ist das
ländern vierte punkt ist die zerstörung
der infrastruktur das läuft unter dem
strich ein euphemismus von
entmilitarisierung das ergebnis danach
ist wirklich ein untergeordneter staat
dass das aus sicht von präsident seinen
ski ein no go ist muss völlig klar sein
das heißt die die alternative die sich
für ihn nur stellt ist gegebenenfalls
sich in die west ukraine zurückzuziehen
das heißt eine ein aufgeben steht
zumindest verstehe ich das jetzt so
eigentlich nicht zur debatte steht nicht
ist kein keinen keine option die auf dem
tisch liegen würde
jetzt haben wir inzwischen schon fragen
und ich will sie sofort weiter reicht
nämlich an den diplomaten tim guldimann
da schreibt wie youtube für alexander
hanel kann diplomatie nicht nur dann
glaubwürdig sein wenn wir in deutschland
wirklich alle gas öl und kohle
lieferungen aus russland sofort
einstellen das ist also die frage was
kann der westen eigentlich noch tun wo
ja jetzt eigentlich an fast alle
sanktions karten auf dem tisch liegen
ich glaube es hängt nicht davon ab wie
stark diese sanktion sind für die
möglichkeit dass irgendeine gefunden
wird bzw ob mit einem waffenstillstand
verhandlungen eingeleitet werden können
die irgendwie
erwartbar mögliche erfolge erzielen
können erfolgen sind dass es nicht so
rauskommt wie jetzt die position aus
moskau das ziel der operation festgelegt
hat ich glaube ganz fatal ist in dieser
situation man kann sich nicht recht
vorstellen wie putin und seiner vier
fenster länge die diesen krieg lanciert
haben gesichtswahrend aus diesem
schlamassel herauskommen das heißt es
ist die gefahr dass sie eigentlich in
eine situation kommen nur noch die
flucht nach vorne mit einer ganz
massiven gewalt die immer grösser wird
die größerer widerstand wird
jetzt gibt es auch einige kommentare von
userinnen und usern christophe karaba
wie bei youtube was will man da noch
verhandeln putin tut nur noch erpressen
das kann sich die ukraine und der westen
nicht gefallen lassen ein weiterer
schreibt über youtube der wird uns alle
in den abgrund treiben und alle schauen
zu also da gibt es auch große sorgen die
frage ist wie kann man denn überhaupt
noch etwas tun herr guldimann sie haben
zum beispiel sie kennen die ukraine sind
sondergesandter der osze gewesen kosovo
tschetschenien wir haben man muss schon
lange lange zurück gehen den krieg auf
dem balkan erlebt kann man da
irgendwelche lehren daraus ziehen oder
muss man einfach sagen das sind ganz
andere vorzeichen ich meine balkankrieg
hatte die nato in der luft herrschaft
hier ist russland der aggressor am
drücker
wurde gefragt nachdem möglich verändert
diplomatie
bis zu ganz generell gefragt ich glaube
sind man muss unterscheiden zwischen
einerseits der frage ob die beiden
kriegsparteien auf der einen seite die
regierung von seelands auf der anderen
seite die russen verhandeln über
irgendwas und es kann durchaus im
beidseitigen interesse sein das ist die
voraussetzung dass verhandlung zu
irgendetwas führen im beidseitigen wenn
auch nur momentan interesse sein dass
humanitäre korridore
errichtet werden das ist nicht
ausgeschlossen
das hängt natürlich vom weiteren verlauf
ab aber das ist eine geschichte das
zweite wäre dann die frage gibt es die
möglichkeit zwischen beiden seiten sich
zu verständigen sich zu einigen über den
künftigen status der ukraine und ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass die
regierung von seelands gehe nicht
irgendeine marionettenregierung die dann
eingesetzt würde sondern die regierung
von salans cli die souveränität des
staates aufgibt und die grundprinzipien
des völkerrechts quasi nicht mehr als
ausgangslage annimmt um irgendetwas zu
vereinbaren mit den russen etwas ganz
anderes ist die frage diplomatie unsere
haltung vom westen gegenüber russland
und da kann man sagen im moment sind die
kanäle werden zugeschüttet dass es eine
folge der sanktion das bedeutet nicht
dass es nicht zweckmäßig ist weiterhin
den kontakt aufrecht zu erhalten wie das
zum beispiel der französische präsident
marco macht das ist zweckmäßig dass man
überhaupt eine kontakt linie hat ob in
dieser kontakt linien dann was schlaues
verhandelt vereinbart werden kann das
steht in den sternen
sie haben gerade gesagt mark und
telefoniert noch viele kanäle sind
zugeschüttet aber bei der frage welche
personen könnte denn so neutral sein
dass sie vielleicht von beiden seiten
akzeptiert wird wer könnte überhaupt als
verhandler eine rolle spielen welches
land oder welche persönlichkeit da gibt
es also viele antworten viele ideen wir
schauen uns das mal an
bisher haben die gespräche zwischen
moskau und kiew an der grenze zu belarus
stattgefunden das problem das land ist
enger verbündeter russlands von dort
marschieren soldaten in richtung kiel
deshalb würde die ukraine lieber israel
oder china als vermittler einschalten
die ukrainische regierung hofft vor
allem auf die guten beziehungen zwischen
peking und moskau auch der vatikan hat
sich als vermittler angeboten papst
franziskus war bereits vor tagen
persönlich in der russischen botschaft
im kirchenstaat sein oberster diplomat
ist überzeugt es gibt immer raum für
verhandlungen
die schweiz und die türkei sind
ebenfalls bereit zu vermitteln präsident
erdogan fürchtet wohl um die
langfristigen beziehungen zu beiden
ländern auch einzelpersonen werden immer
wieder genannt der russische oligarch
roman abramowitsch bisher als putin
freund bekannt zum beispiel die ukraine
hatte ihn offenbar um hilfe gebeten und
die ehemalige bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel sie kennt den russischen
präsidenten putin seit vielen jahren
sagte bisher aber nichts zu einer
vermittlerrolle so bleibt es bei
angeboten forderungen und gerüchten auch
am tag acht des krieges in der ukraine
fange ich mit ihnen an form erhalten sie
eine von den vorschlägen von den namen
oder ländern die im gespräch sind für
realistisch
ich denke das wird sich im endeffekt in
der praxis zeigen also ich bin zum
beispiel sehr skeptisch was den
vorschlag china angeht weil china ein
verständnis von souveränität hat was
ganz sicherlich nicht mit dem
verständnis der der ukraine zu vereinen
ist das heißt wir müssen de facto
jemanden finden den den russland
respektiert denen die ukraine
respektiert und dem beide zutrauen ein
ehrlicher makler zu sein denn wir haben
diese verschiedenen ebenen der
diplomatie wo angesetzt werden kann oder
angesetzt werden muss die etwas
einfachere ebene der guten behinderung
also auch um die humanitäre katastrophe
zu lindern wo es möglicherweise eher
einigungsmöglichkeiten gibt also jetzt
akut in der krise und die zweite ebene
diese politische frage die ich anfangs
schon sagte die nicht so die nicht
einfach zu lösen sein wird nämlich
ukraine bild souverän bleiben russland
will einen bei seinem start und dann
gibt es die dritte ebene ist wie wollen
wir eigentlich als europäer in zukunft
mit russland in europa zusammenleben wie
bauen wir unsere neue ordnung auch die
friedensordnung kooperativer und die wir
vorher hatten die es vom tisch das heißt
wie werden wir europäer in zukunft mit
russland was immer noch in europa ist
aber deutlich konfrontativer auch steht
nach welchen regeln werden wir in
zukunft leben und auf diesen drei ebenen
der verhandlungen kann man bei der
ersten vielleicht mit hilfe von israel
fortschritte machen aber die anderen
beiden ebenen das ist kein sprint das
ist ein dauerlauf dass wir anfragen
seien die uns noch mehrere jahre
beschäftigen werden und wo keine
einfache lösung in sicht ist das heißt
wir müssen glaube ich nicht einigen wer
kann das machen sondern auch in welchem
prozess man das machen kann damit man so
sagen langfristig versuchen kann diese
fragen
anzugehen ich sage nicht mal lösen ich
sage einfach nur interessieren der gute
mann nicht
stimmen zu was müsste ein verhandler
mitbringen dass er eben akzeptiert wird
was sind die kriterien
ich glaube erstens ist die frage viel zu
früh und zweitens halte ich es für
irrelevant wer das macht man könnte sich
einfach fragen wer ist und das problem
liegt in erster linie in moskau ich
glaube nicht dass das problem in der
ukraine liegt wer welche macht oder wie
auch immer welche person ist imstande
dem kreml die möglichkeit zu geben
gesichtswahrend hier irgendwie
herauszukommen und beginne davon aus
dass putin die person ist und je länger
der krieg dauert desto schwieriger ist
es für putin hier irgendwie denn die
kurve zu kriegen um eine akzeptanz
akzeptablen lösung zuzustimmen ich
glaube da sind wir sehr weit entfernt
davon jetzt darüber zu sprechen ob es
der vatikan oder china machen kann ich
glaube das ist viel zu früh es ist ja
auch so dass die jetzt miteinander
sprechen sie sprechen beide seite
russisch ist aber kein problem braucht
nicht mal an die besetzer das ist nicht
die frage die frage ist was wollen
angesprochen worden ist was sind die
etappen die ich hoffe im humanitären
interesse dass man sich einigen kann auf
korridore auch auf die möglichkeit der
zivilbevölkerung dass sie ihn verlassen
kann dann droht der stadt natürlich eine
ganz üble zerstörung und dann haben wir
wahrscheinlich eine auseinandersetzung
wie es jetzt ausschaut mit der mit dem
widerstand der ukrainischen bevölkerung
einer langen auseinandersetzung
allenfalls auch ein geringer
allenfalls auch eine regierung irgendwo
im wald das weiß man noch nicht für den
fall dass die russen ist überhaupt
erreichen die regierung aus kiew zu
vertreiben oder ein fass festzunehmen
und umzubringen wie 1956 in
ungarn also es sind verschiedene
szenarien offen und davon hängt dann
auch ab was realistischerweise
vereinbart werden könnte um diese
katastrophe etwas einhalt zu geben das
sind ja doch ziemlich auch düstere
szenarien und auch die userinnen und
user sagen ich frage mich wie ein
kompromiss aussehen könnte schreibt eine
über youtube ein anderer zur seele 100
schreiben was kann man putin ich nehme
es deckt sich mit dem was sie sagen hat
wohl jemand was kann man den putin
anbieten damit er sein gesicht wahren
kann und sozusagen diesen krieg stoppt
ich will auf einen punkt kommen denn
unser korrespondent christian semler
eben genannt hat das russische
verteidigungsministerium frau maria
musste zugeben inzwischen das 498
russische soldaten bisher getötet worden
sind
1597 seien verwundet worden also zahlen
des russischen verteidigungsministeriums
elends gesagt heute 9000 russische
soldaten seien getötet worden die zahl
dass wir jetzt einfach mal aber wenn das
vom verteidigungsministerium schon mal
eine solche zahl ist kann am ende ein
sehr hoher blutzoll am ende dazu führen
dass die menschen noch mehr auf die
straße gehen das ist sagen wir jetzt mal
salopp eines in ein umsturz gibt dass es
für putin zu eng wird ist dass irgendein
szenario
ich möchte aber auch die freiburger vor
zurückkommen ich glaube dass wir als
westeuropäer keine angebote machen
sollten wie russland aus dem aktuellen
der aktuellen ecke raus kommen können
denn was heißt es jetzt angebote zu
machen glaube wir sollten keinerlei
angebote machen wie man die ukraine
teilen könnte oder wie man bestimmte
teile ab trennen könnte es geht um die
um einen souveränen staat was sollen das
für angebote seien angebote die jetzt
sozusagen im raum stehen für eine
gesichtswahrende lösung gehen auf kosten
der ukraine das muss man so ganz klar
benennen und deswegen finde ich sollte
mir sehr vorsichtig sein mit welche
angebote können wir jetzt machen gerade
mit blick auf die ukraine den anderen
punkt den sie angesprochen hätten die in
die zahlen ich glaube was enorm wichtig
ist sich immer wieder in erinnerung zu
führen dass dieser krieg dieser konflikt
auch im informationsraum stattfindet das
ist von beiden seiten ein sehr großes
bestreben gibt die kontrolle über das
narrativ über die bilder über die zahlen
und anderes zu machen das kann man in
vielen bereichen sehen das kann man an
der wortwahl sehen wenn russland
beispielsweise von einer
entnazifizierung spricht was de facto
heißt die gesamten eliten abzulösen
dieses wort sollte man nicht benutzen
das kann man daran sehen wann russland
von verhandlungen spricht im endeffekt
geht es darum dass russland der ukraine
eine kapitulation anbietet dann sollte
man das auch so nennen das heißt wir
müssen sehr aufpassen welche bilder und
welche negative wir übernehmen und ganz
viel davon ist wirklich signaling in das
eigene land oder gegenüber dem westen
und deshalb müssen wir immer sehr
vorsichtig sein informationen zu
überprüfen und auch zu gucken wie wir
über diesen konflikt reden weil das
immer auch teil sozusagen das dass der
konflikt und des krieges ist die
berichterstattung darüber und auch die
wortwahl
jetzt möchte ich aber auf meine frage
einfach noch mal zurückkommen also sie
beide da sind wir uns ja eigentlich
einig gehen eben hin dass man der westen
kann putin keine angebote machen man
kann nicht die ukraine irgendwie teilen
man kann ich sagen wärst du denn
zufrieden wenn du vielleicht den don
bass chris die militärische lage das was
putin macht spricht offene bände will
eben nicht nur einfach den don was unter
kontrolle bringen sondern die komplette
ukraine sie beide haben es gesagt und
insofern kommt man da nicht zusammen
dass
niemand sie wollen unterbrechen nein ich
glaube ich nehme mir nur das auf ganz
klar sagte weil sie sagte er möchte die
ukraine zu einem vasallenstaat machen
und der ehemalige nato general ramms der
vor ausbruch des krieges hier am
dienstag war mit einem livestream sagte
eben putin hat vor allen dingen wenn man
in die geschichte schaut was er
geschrieben hat eben dieses dreieck auch
vor augen einerseits kränkt ihn eben
dass die sowjetunion zusammengebrochen
ist und er träumt eben auch wieder von
diesem dreieck moskau minsk kiew dass
das eben unter seiner kontrolle ist frau
major hat gesagt was ein staat das
wollte ich aufnehmen sehen sie das ich
glaube man kann ruhig ein angebot machen
auf der basis des völkerrechts also ich
glaube wichtig ist dass man investiert
auf die print auf den prinzipien die
anerkannt werden müssen wenn russland
und dann kann man sagen wir sind sehr
gerne bereit konstruktiv irgendeine
lösung zu finden was auch die
sicherheitsarchitektur in europa
betrifft was auch die zukunft von der
ukraine betrifft die
ukraine als souveräner staat selbst
entscheiden können und wenn man das
festhält kann man sehr gerne sagen ja
wir sind immer bereit mit dir putin
darüber zu sprechen das ist einfach die
grundlage und für uns geht es nicht an
dass wir an diesen prinzipien
irgendwelche konzessionen machen und
sagen es ist nicht so wichtig konkret
wenn man sagt die krim es gibt ja
stimmen die gesagt haben man müsse doch
vielleicht völkerrechtlich anerkennen
dass die krim zu russland gehört nein
aber man kann sagen das problem der
creme muss auf der basis des
völkerrechtes gelöst werden bedeutet
zwei souveräne staaten können sich
einigen was ist die zukunft der krim
wenn die ukraine sich mit russland daher
nicht über die zukunft der krim kann man
von außen sagen okay das entspricht dem
völkerrecht entscheidend ist die
anerkennung der souveränität des staates
der ukraine und wenn man dann zurück
geht das ist ja die große verletzung von
putin und das habe ich erlebt als ich da
mit dem schweizerischen
bundespräsidentin drei bis vier stunden
bei ihm im kreml war ich konnte den
herrn burkhalter begleiten interessant
war da wie besessen geradezu putin von
der nato von der ost erweiterung von der
gefahr dass die ukraine insbesondere ins
westliche lager abdriftet und das möchte
vermeiden also hier gibt's in russischer
sicht der aktiv das aus meiner sicht
sehr gerne aufgenommen werden kann und
da muss man feststellen von westlicher
seite sind serienweise große fehler
gemacht worden in der demütigung von
russland beispiel obama faktor sagt
russland sei eine regionale macht das
ist für die supermacht des kalten
krieges natürlich eine beleidigung also
das ist alles akkumulierte frustration
das kann man gerne zu gestehen darüber
kann man sprechen aber nicht wird das
prinzip dass souveränität der ukraine
dann nämlich genau das guldimann und
frage genau sie daneben frau maja wenn
man das aufnimmt und sagte putin ist
eben gekränkt ein enttäuschter
verletzter entfesselter diktator ist er
denn dann irgendwie sozusagen wieder
noch einzufangen mit westlichen mitteln
also ich glaube ich
finde es wichtig darauf hinzuweisen was
die realistischen annahmen oder die
realistischen erwartungen von solchen
behandlungen sind es ist wichtig auch
die grundlagen des völkerrechts
hinzuweisen wir haben aber in der
vergangenheit auch gesehen dass das für
russland kein maßstab ist dh die
realistische erwartungshaltung wie
erfolgversprechend so eine verhandlung
sein kann müssen wir ehrlich anerkennen
das ist sehr gering es gab bislang wenig
bis kein interesse von russland auf
diese sich auch diese verhandlungen oder
austauschen zu lassen
was was kann sozusagen noch eine
veränderung bewirken ich glaube was wir
uns ganz klar vor augen führen ist dass
russland nach einer anderen logik oder
nach einer anderen nationalität handelt
als wir was russland oder was putin im
kopf hat ist nicht das was wir nationale
sicherheit nennen würden sondern es ist
regime sicherheit das heißt das
überleben seines systems und damit
handelt er auch nach einer anderen logik
als wir möglicherweise in den westlichen
staaten handeln würden ich gebe ihnen
ein beispiel die westlichen staaten
haben das umfangreichste sanktionen
paket verhängt was jemals verhängt
worden ist wo ein international
wirtschaftlich eng vernetzter staaten
wie russland von heute auf morgen
abgeschnitten wurde das wird enorme
folgen haben aber die reaktion russland
zwar nicht ebenfalls mit
wirtschaftlichen sanktionen zu reagieren
sondern
sicherheitspolitisch zu reagieren indem
die nuts in dem die abschreckungskräfte
darunter erzählen auch die nuklearwaffen
in alarmbereitschaft versetzt wurden das
heißt es folgt das russische handeln
erfolgt einer anderen logik einer
anderen rationalität
als die der westeuropäischen staaten und
diesen unterschied müssen wir vor augen
haben das heißt nämlich auch dass wir
von solchen verhandlungen
die sind wichtig wir müssen die kanäle
aufrecht erhalten wir müssen aber eine
realistische erwartung haben was sie
bringen können nämlich extrem wenig
eine klare analyse die nicht gerade
optimistisch stimmt von ihnen beiden
aber wir werden das ganze schauen und
den danken ihnen ganz herzlich für diese
informationen eben auch wenn sie sagen
dass man vielleicht die augen an das
öffnen muss um auf diesen konflikt auf
putin eben auch anders zu schauen ich
danke ganz ganz ganz herzlich auch im
namen der user für ihr engagement das
sie die fragen beantwortet haben vielen
dank für das einordnen viele grüße und
vielen dank und auch an sie vielen dank
dass sie mit dabei waren fragen gestellt
haben und das ganze mit uns besprochen
haben es bleibt also schwierig tag 8 des
angriffskriegs auf die ukraine viele
fragen sind weiterhin offen und wir
haben es gehört es gibt auch düstere
szenarien vielen dank für ihr interesse